this morning we are highlighting two
pioneering women who've become leaders
and Role Models Condoleezza Rice was the
first black woman to serve as Secretary
of State and Allison Felix is the most
decorated U.S Olympian and track and
field history and track and field
history she's trying to say they
recently spoke at the kpmg's women's
Leadership Summit at the baltus roll
golf club that's in New Jersey where
they met up with Adriana Diaz in a
preview last week rice shared her
thoughts on China and former president
Donald Trump they're now working
together to help other women in their
careers by prioritizing Wellness
nobody ever sets out to actually be the
first I'll never forget a conversation
with my good friend the late Sally Ride
and she said I didn't want to be the
first woman in space I just wanted to be
in space and so I think if you think too
much about being the first you won't
enjoy the opportunity before you enjoy
the ride so to enjoy the ride that's
right yeah the ride to the top wasn't
always smooth for former Secretary of
State Condoleezza Rice and track and
field Olympian Alice and Felix I grew up
in segregated Birmingham Alabama and if
I had thought about barriers I wouldn't
be where I am today my father had a very
good way of saying it don't let somebody
else's Prejudice be your problem it's
difficult to be the only one in the room
but I think there is there's freedom on
the other side of fear Felix once feared
losing her livelihood if she didn't hide
a part of her truth I was training at
4am while it was dark so that no one
would see that I was pregnant that's
because at the time in 2018 she says her
sponsor Nike would reduce athletes pay
if they couldn't compete even if they
were sidelined by pregnancy she went
public in a New York Times op-ed I went
through that very hard time right when I
was having my daughter and just looking
at her and thinking about the world that
I want her to grow up in I was
absolutely terrified but I deeply
believed I was doing what was right Nike
changed its policy and Felix went on to
found her own athletic shoe company Sage
here I am
ready to run for a brand that I founded
which aims to support women especially
mothers you've long spoken out about
black maternal Health most recently
about your friend and former teammate
Tori Bowie I think it's been a really
hard situation for everyone and it's
just highlighted that we are facing a
maternal Health crisis for women of
color Bowie died in May from
complications during childbirth an
autopsy reveals she may have had
seizures stemming from pre-eclampsia a
high blood pressure condition that
disproportionately affects black women
the CDC says that black women are three
times more likely to die from a
pregnancy-related complication it's 80
percent preventable what can the
healthcare world do and also what can
black women do themselves women of color
have to know that they're at risk they
have to know the signs to look for you
know their Vision being impaired
swollen feet headaches the awareness you
know implicit bias training you know in
the medical field
in the past black women have not been
heard they haven't their pain hasn't
been believed and that just has to stop
Health child care and work are all
contributing to higher stress levels in
a new KPMG study 91 percent of executive
women report feeling an exponential
growth in stress over the last three
years is that something that you've
observed or you've experienced stress is
a part of life
and particularly as you go up the ladder
it's going to be more stressful and and
frankly that's also true for men Dr Rice
I can't imagine the stressful situations
you've been in especially in your
diplomatic life what tools do you use to
manage and navigate stress
I always found first and foremost
acknowledging it
if you suppress it it doesn't help I
always said to myself all right this is
a stressful situation and by naming it I
felt that I could deal with it then and
saying oh I can't be stressed
come on what you can see is I'm feeling
stressed how do I manage that stress and
I think that's the the most important
thing Allison for you what are your
Wellness practices yeah and I start my
day off with my gratitude journal and
that really just centers me and started
playing a little bit of tennis sometimes
in my days get absolutely crazy
sometimes Wellness looks like sitting in
my car for a little bit longer you know
doing a little bit of meditation before
I walk into the house
both say practicing Wellness has been
key
their success for rice that means
playing piano
and making time to unplug even when I
was secretary I would take the time
between noon and seven o'clock on
Sundays and I would say now if you have
to call me do but if you don't let me
watch football on TV her love of
football is more than just a hobby she's
also part owner of the Denver Broncos my
father who's Gone to Heaven is probably
thinks I finally got an important job
you know
it's about time my dad he was a football
coach when I was born and some of my
happiest memories are are watching
football with my dad so I can remember
it you know six or seven years old
Condoleezza what are they doing Daddy
that's a trap block or that's they're
setting up a screen daddy lifelong
memories Felix also wants to impart to
her daughter I try to speak life into
her we do affirmations I just want her
to be really confident because I know at
some point she'll have to take on her
own battles and I want her to be really
ready for Matt what was today's
affirmation we haven't done it yet but I
think it's going to be um challenges
Help Me Grow
thank you Adriana Diaz don't we like
Candy's Dad don't let someone else's
Prejudice be your problem or Allison
there's freedom on the other side of
Freer love that